welcome to episode 34 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this podcast dad jordan peterson and
i spoke with
mr coleman hughes in reality
dad did most of the talking with coleman
it was the first podcast he's done
with someone other than me in almost two
years as you guys might know he's been
incredibly ill with something called
akathesia
and i thought maybe i could get him to
do a podcast if i had
everything set up and he just had to
walk in and do it
so here it is there's going to be
another one released next week with wim
hof
2. i didn't actually do much talking on
this podcast i was really just
enjoying watching my dad work i hope you
enjoy it too
and now a quick word from the wonderful
people who make this podcast possible
first we have merty creative co they
make a fantastic
leather-bound journal
mine's a bit scuffed as you can see here
i actually designed my original logo in
this
it's scuffed because i've had it for
quite a while and i've used it a lot
with codemp you can get free engravings
they also have
folios binders and other leather goods
made in the u.s of a
a great place to buy a christmas present
or a gratefulness journal given the fact
it's thanksgiving they also have a
podcast available you can find it on
youtube
at mertycreative.co they talk about
making a small business which is pretty
relevant given the fact that businesses
are basically having to move
online but i would recommend these guys
for christmas gifts
again that's mertycreative.com and use
codemp
for free engravings and to tell them you
came from here
and the second sponsor for this episode
makes the cutest or if you're manly
the manliest leather wallets i have
their parliament wallet
you can press a button and your cards
come out
which is pretty convenient
i like how it looks small it's simple
it's leather
and one of the cool parts of this
is you can actually track it with an app
they provide so if you lose it
not that anybody's really doing anything
this year but if you did lose it
you could find it so their website is
extra
ekster.com and with code mp you get five
percent off
they make excellent christmas gifts as
well uh they usually have
some sort of promo going on so it's five
percent on top of whatever promo going
on
highly recommend them for christmas
gifts as well ekster.com
code mp i hope you enjoyed this episode
as much as i did
it was lovely to see dad doing some kind
of work like this again
if you liked the episode please rate and
subscribe and check out my newsletter
which is linked in the show notes
and available at michaelapeterson.com to
stay in touch
[Music]
hi there everyone we're privileged
tonight to have
as a guest mr coleman hughes who
is one of the most promising young
intellectuals on the american scene
i met him a couple of years ago at a
function i think it was in new york
although it might have been in
washington was it new york
it was new york where i heard him speak
as well and was extraordinarily
impressed and so we're going to talk to
him
tonight about his ideas and coleman it's
great to see you
let us know what you're up to great to
be seen uh i'm
i'm here in new york hunkering down
during
the sort of second quasi lockdown that
we're experiencing i am
happy at work on my first book which i
just
finalized the contract for
and i'm working on my own podcast we've
released
15 or 20 episodes so far called
conversations with coleman
and i am enjoying all of the work
that i'm doing and very happy to be
speaking with you do you want to say a
few
words about your book the book is a
defense of colorblindness
colorblindness with respect to race the
notion that
we should strive to treat people without
regard to race
and eliminate uh racial categories
as a
criteria on which to base public policy
it's something that is enormously
unpopular
in elite circles but still
enjoys widespread support in the public
in the general public so i'm trying to
make
the the best defense of the colorblind
ideal that i possibly can
because i think it's a enormously
important principle
uh to defend and to have the language to
defend
so if you if you made a case for the
people who hold the contrary position
that that race for example or
or perhaps ethnicity or even cultural
background might instead
be regarded as a category of critical
importance
how would they justify their particular
perspective
i think uh you could justify the
opposing perspective
in a number of different ways i i would
say the
the strongest would be to appeal uh to
to critique the notion
that uh that racism is merely
uh a psychological phenomenon
in the minds of individuals a deviation
from rational and objective treatment
because of somebody's
skin color you can make the case that
because of the
circumstances of american history
slavery
jim crow redlining convict leasing all
of the ways in which
black americans were subjugated uh given
that particular history it makes sense
for
black americans to form a group
consciousness and to practice
group-based politics and that
uh you can't abstract away from the
circumstances
of that history and um to individu to
their individual status
that's right yeah well it's a tricky one
isn't it because
race at least some forms of race
racial distinctions are pretty obvious
perceptually
and so to talk about eliminating their
use as a
cognitive category let's say a
conceptual category
um seems
what would you say problematic at least
in some in some regards right it's some
effort to become colorblind and um
the argument that because of history
race might might be used at least in
some circumstances as a
factor for promotion of
let's say um um affirmative action
policies
it certainly struck many people as a
powerful argument
so what do you do you you in your book
you're obviously going to take this
argument on despite its
its power yeah so the very first thing i
i plan to do in the book is clarify what
i
don't mean by the admittedly misleading
word colorblind
colorblind is a word like warm-hearted
when you describe someone as
warm-hearted
you're not literally talking about the
temperature of their blood-pumping organ
you're speaking about the kindness of
their spirit
likewise with colorblind it's a it's a
it's a word that employs a physical
metaphor
of not being able to see color to name
an underlying principle
which is to strive to treat people
without regard to their race
and to enshrine race neutral public
policy
the notion that we could ever completely
get to a place where
we are truly colorblind which is to say
you almost
in the literal sense you you you
basically don't even notice people's
color is naive and utopian um
but but it seems it's funny too though
you know to argue the other side for a
moment is that
it it doesn't seem logical in many
circumstances to use race as a criteria
for judgment because race per se has
little or nothing to do with let's say
desired outcomes for the task at hand if
you're doing something like hiring
or if you're engaged in any activity
with someone else that has an
end in mind you should judge the people
with whom that pursuit is going to be
undertaken
on criteria that have something to do
with their ability to
manage the pursuit yeah so it seems
purely logical to
in some sense to be race blind i mean
that's the argument that people make
when
when stating that prejudice is its own
punishment
because you lose if you're prejudiced
against women for
example or for your prejudice against
someone from a different racial
background then you
lose the ability to hire them let's say
and and therefore
decrease your pool of talent
yeah that's that's gary becker's uh the
economist famous theory of
discrimination and there's
certainly something to be to be said for
that i i just um
i just read an mpr interview with
a public health official who was talking
about the coronavirus vaccine
and how they plan to triage the vaccine
once it's available who's going to get
the vaccine first
second and third and uh the
what this person laid out made total
sense it was the
the people with you know uh um
conditions that comorbidities and the
elderly would get it first
um and then people like me perfectly
healthy 24 year olds would be last in
line
and then the npr interview asked them
given
the fact that communities of color are
disproportionately affected
uh do you you know it was pressing her
this
person to inject race as a category or a
criterion
among the risk factors and you can
you can here in the interview uh
the the public health official getting a
little bit
nervous and dancing around the issue a
little bit
but saying not in so many words we're
just going to
look at the risk factors themselves and
inevitably
if black people are disproportionately
uh
having comorbidities or having risk
factors then
our our our race neutral system will
inevitably favor them
um as as a side effect but we don't need
to use race as a
as a proxy because it's such a poor
proxy
for any given thing in this world that
you could care about whether that is
uh getting the best sound editor for
your podcast
um or whether it's um
you know vaccinating the highest risk
populations first
so many of the arguments i make in the
book
are arguments to stop using race as a
an imperfect proxy for things like
socioeconomics
public health and merit
why did you decide to take this on you
know i mean it's obviously not something
that's going to make you particularly
popular
and i i think you have a history of
taking on topics of that sort i mean
what's what's driving you to do this
well i think um
i think there is there's something
slowly slipping away from us as a
culture that's worth
holding on to and i feel um
that from roughly ages zero to 16 i was
living
about as colorblind a life as
one could i i effortlessly had
white friends black friends hispanic
friends and asian friends
i i didn't think of race as anything
more
than something to occasionally make a
joke about
and when you know on the rare instances
where i did encounter racism
i felt something closer to pity than
anger for
the racist the small-minded bigot it was
obvious
to me and everyone i knew why racism was
evil
i grew up feeling goosebumps watching
martin luther king's i have a dream
speech as many people do
but around the time i was 16 which would
be 2012
i started to get a a a download of an
entire entirely different kind of
anti-racist ideology
that explicitly rejected aspirational
color blindness
which told me that by definition as a
black person i was a victim
of of white supremacy which encouraged
me to focus
on on any
way no matter how miniscule in which i
had been
made a victim of white supremacy
and um it seemed to me that this was not
something that was encouraging a closer
collaboration
and closer intimacy between people of
different races but was in fact
creating neuroticism and paranoia
around people of different races now
there's a
there's a an expectation oh you know as
i'm talking to this person is this a
person who's gonna
um assume that i i'm worried about
microaggressions all the time and
therefore keep their guard up
or in the reverse is this a person who
is
you know highly self-conscious of
quote-unquote white privilege and now it
just like it
it creates a a space of nerves and
anxiety around race and dishonesty
that i found was not in any
way shape or form fighting racism
um but was was making people racially
neurotic
do you think that the effects of
of that highlighting of of
race as a defining characteristic
has particularly pernicious effects in
like the white community or the black
community or do you think that it's
equally pernicious across communities
that's a good question um i suppose it
affects
uh folks in different ways um i i know
for for white for white people there's a
i think there's a dividing line between
white people who
feel uh what is often called white guilt
and those who don't and i think shelby
steele's point
um is worth reiterating which is that
white guilt is really misnamed it's not
really guilt it's a terror at the notion
that you might be racist that you might
be part of the problem
um that uh
and that you might be seen by others as
racist it's a it's a
a deep terror and um i think
those white people who do feel that
often end up
doing um strange and
unhealthy things in order to
relieve that feeling of terror um
they often end up you know
debasing themselves and playing the the
masochist
or um turning off the
skeptical portion of their brain at any
claim a black person makes
right which is a real debasing of the
conversation
yeah that's a terrible that's a terrible
that's a terrible thing to do to an
interaction
to make it so that real communication
can't take place
yep and and on the other side um
with black people what it encourages us
to do is to
to hone in on everything that's
uh to blame the world and society
for everything that has gone wrong in
our lives
uh which is uh it it it encourages us to
get a sense of meaning and identity
out of the notion that we are victims
that the that society is arrayed against
us
that we are part part of a noble
struggle against us
against a society that is fundamentally
hostile
to people who look like us you can you
can see what a
pervasive problem it is a because
last five or six minutes of this
conversation
both you and i automatically assumed
that there would be something in common
about what
the idea of race as a category does to
white people and perhaps something
different about what it does to black
people
you know i'm just bringing that up to to
show
how tricky it is to manage
the notion of colorblindness given the
given the perceptual presence of racial
differences
so i often find
for what it's worth that children
tend to understand colorblindness
intuitively much more easily than adults
do
they understand how how skin color is
you know skin deep it doesn't mean
anything more than
than you make it mean um
and so i i often feel that we are
miseducating
our children or or or um reiterating and
re-um reifying our own racial neuroses
and perpetrating them
on the next generation generation after
generation
i was going to say growing up in toronto
was pretty multicultural
and i didn't like my best friends were i
guess
half black i didn't notice and like and
like you i grew up with
having friends that were you know asian
black whatever
um and i don't think i noticed anything
until i think i'm a little bit older
than you so i think it started in
university
when people started talking about race
more
um but yeah but i really didn't notice
especially when i was like little no it
was one of the delightful things about
being in toronto was that
that that ideal of race blindness
yeah was really yeah had really been
achieved i would say in many regards
when i when i went to montreal actually
um and there were more
middle eastern people and there were um
less black people i actually noticed
that there was like something missing
kind of there when i moved to montreal
but growing up in toronto
it was pretty good for that kind of
thing it does seem more recent and i do
agree that
it's not good for people it's made me
uncomfortable about who i'm talking to
not based on their skin color but based
on what they
think about skin color whether or not
i'm going to be blamed for something
or whether or not there's already some
animosity between us
that's exactly the kind of neurosis that
i'm i'm speaking of and i think
particularly in the past six months with
the
explosion of
social justice and anti-racism as a
result
of the death of george floyd in police
custody and the
protests and riots that ensued um
there's a whole you know a whole
underbelly of
um you know broken friendships
and uh you know
brand new neuroses that people have
developed as a result of
seeing uh politics
political demands that cleave the world
into good and evil
imported inst into their instagram feed
every day
and and essentially been asked to pick a
side
in a very simplistic caricature of the
problem
and uh made to feel evil if they have
any kind of
you know skepticism about it so that
that problem that you described i mean
i was reading some of the things that
you wrote a couple of years ago today
and
uh including your review of some of
thomas soule's work the
the economist and um you talked about
inequality essentially like it seems to
me that what drives the
continual discussion of race
particularly in the united states
because it's less intense here in canada
is pervasive inequality um
particularly inequality between let's
say the caucasian majority
although i don't believe it's a majority
anymore it's still close to a majority
and the
and the black minority um
the fact that that inequality continues
to exist
seems to be the motivating factor for
the supposition that racial prejudice is
still alive and well
but you reviewed documentation and i
think this was from seoul as well
that showed that black immigrants to the
united states
weren't characterized by the same levels
of
the same levels of inequality did not
obtain between black immigrants to the
united states
and caucasians
who were native to the u.s so to speak
it was only the case for blacks who were
born in the u.s
yes that's correct okay so that's that's
a real that's really troublesome
in about five different directions it's
troublesome because
the fact of the inequality drives the
presupposition that racism still exists
but the fact that the inequality doesn't
seem to exist in the case of immigrants
casts doubt on the claim that it is in
fact
racism that's producing the inequality
and then you're left with a question
which is the question i wanted to pose
to you
you know you talked about you've written
about cultural differences
do you think that there are cultural
differences among
the black community in the united states
that is driving inequality forward is it
i mean i think that's even a more
what would you call incendiary topic
than the ones that we've been discussing
yes it is an incendiary topic but it's
also
very plausibly true um and it's
i think people are very terrified of
this topic and they really shouldn't be
they have a notion that a if
if there are if cultural differences and
differences in behavior patterns
at the median or at the mean in
different populations
is the driving force behind unequal
outcomes
then that means we can't possibly fix it
whereas if
it's systemic racism then that's
something we can fix
i think that's uh that's probably a
a large exaggeration on both counts
i again i'm not i'm not necessarily the
person that is going to
lead a movement to to uh
fix behavioral behavioral patterns for
example
how how many hours the average black
student studies per night compared
to how many hours the average white
student or
or asian student studies because there
is also a large gap
on that score between whites and asians
but i do think that local community
groups can
make a difference in those areas
not only that i think it's i think
there's an unreflective assumption
that systemic fixing systemic racism
and to to give an example or or
whether we want to call this systemic is
a separate question but fixing
a phenomenon of racial bias widespread
throughout an
industry such as real estate agents
treating black homeowners
uh different than they than they do
white homeowners
that's i'm not sure that's so easy to
fix or any easier to fix
than a cultural problem because they
both
involve changing the behavior of people
in private moments
when they may not have an incentive to
well that's a big danger between
reflexively assuming that prejudice is
that the
is the fundamental cause of the
inequality that that
that is driving the the
the debate the fact of that inequality
is that
is tragic and it's not going to be
remediated or repaired until we actually
get the causal story correct
and what that would mean if you were a
good social scientist investigating this
is that you would look at a whole array
of potentially causal factors
in an attempt to specify exactly what it
is that
is contributing you'd probably find that
there were multiple factors
you know and hopefully they would be
small enough so that some of them could
be remediated
there's some reason that that black
immigrants to the u.s do better
there's something going on there i don't
know what it is i don't know the
literature well enough
i want to propose
a reason why i don't think
inequality is as tragic as it seems
i think truly poverty and
intergenerational poverty
is tragic and we have to separate that
from inequality because they're
conceptually different
inequality you know taking a snapshot of
the country at a particular
time were you comparing this group of 40
40 million
black people in a freeze frame to um you
know over
a hundred million uh white people
and looking at a single number that
describes
how they're doing which is is is just a
mean
what that doesn't capture is for example
the fact that
this generation of black americans is
doing much
much much better than their parents so
something like
70 percent of uh black americans report
on the federal reserve survey that
they're doing uh
they're better off financially than
their parents which is actually a higher
percentage
than of of whites who say the same wow
so there's two there's two ways
importantly different ways to look at
this you can compare
a group to itself at an earlier point in
time
and if you do this with black americans
you know huge progress on health you
know rates of death from cancer going
down life expectancy going up
incarceration rates especially for black
americans in their 20s have
more than cut in half since i was in
kindergarten
or you can you get a very different
picture if you
compare two different groups at the same
time where one group had had a massive
head start in every way imaginable
it could be the case that both are
making rather fantastic progress but so
long as one
is ahead it will look like nothing's
changing if you're only looking at the
gaps between them rather than
the objective progress they're making
so the um the the racial issue in the
united states is often framed too
in terms of discrimination against
blacks on the
part of caucasians and let's say the
white supremacy that has
emerged as a consequence of that but
that also
um seems to fail as a hypothesis given
the staggering success let's say of
indian americans and of asian americans
in general
because if it was a an issue that was
somehow related to
the caucasian community per se
you'd think that we they
would have been just as efficient at
holding back the progress of those other
groups as
holding back the progress of the black
community
i feel like asian americans aren't even
involved they're
they're doing really well and we're
squabbling about race problems
yeah it's strange that it's it does seem
like that i don't
i don't really understand that um
their success is an embarrassment to the
theory
um that white supremacy is crushing
how do you for example say what what has
been said about
standardized test scores standardized
tests rather like the sat and act that
they are
they are created by europeans for
europeans and are culturally biased in
very subtle ways that you know
there's some hand waving that's done
here but the point is the test is made
by white people for white people
and then asians come with no particular
background in european culture and
destroy the white people on this test
right on average so again it's an
embarrassment to the theory
that all of society is tilted um
in in favor of white people in subtle
and not so subtle ways
and a lot of that with the asians a lot
of that does seem to be a consequence of
of work habits i mean i looked into
asian versus caucasian performance in
the u.s
a number of decades ago for a federal
government project that i was doing at
the time
and the asians
this was the children of first
generation asian immigrants because the
effect seems to go away by about three
generations
maybe because their asians are more
thoroughly enculturated into the
american community but
the children of first generation asian
immigrants worked hard enough so that
that um served as the equivalent to 15
additional iq points
which is roughly the difference between
the typical state university student and
the typical high school
student so that's a good example too of
of of a situation where cultural
differences really seem to play a role
yes and i've seen i've seen data to that
effect
uh in the us as well which suggests that
just
you know it's not that there's there's
uh
what's explaining it is a genetic
difference it's that
it's that you know it's like more hours
spent studying on average it's
mom and dad over the shoulder um you
know
making sure that you do your homework
and you do it right
um that phenomenon is not
equally represented in every culture and
it's underrepresented
among black americans well that's
that'll be a statement that'll
definitely make you popular again
so what what makes you how do you know
that
good question um so that we do have we
do have
survey evidence you know
on self-report surveys of how
how much how many hours per night
students study um brookings has done
work on this it's it's a it's a taboo
subject so i think most
academics understandably uh
stay away from it um we have
uh extensive data from nielsen which is
a
one of the leading market research firms
and of the famous
nielsen television ratings which
investigate everything from what people
spend their money on to how many hours
of tv
people watch per day and breaks it down
by race
and you find big differences in all of
these things
differences that are consequential if
you
are concerned about closing gaps in
say wealth accrual and income and
and all of these things so do
will your book contain
solutions i mean to these to these
cultural problems
just because they're cultural doesn't
mean they're easy to solve obviously
right
um any more than they would be easy to
solve if they were a consequence of
prejudice
or biological factors um
but it isn't it isn't obvious how to get
from
the situation that you're describing to
to somewhere better
yeah you know my book is is for adults
it's not it's not it's not for children
that want an easy
solution to everything it's for people
who
recognize the inherent trade-offs and
the complexity in the world
and it's not to say that there will be
no solutions offered
i think there are probably more
clear-cut solutions to
problems like problems of policing and
criminal justice
than education but i do think
incremental progress is possible
and i'm not uh i'm i'm not
i'm not selling a a solution
really i think um um i think
you know many people have just
understandably grown skeptical of people
who come and say oh well i've got the
solution
um it's it's simple i've done all the
analysis
i know everything that's wrong and the
solution is simple and it just requires
us
to not be evil right i think the world
is
is far too complicated and has far too
many trade-offs for that so
the book is about um defending
uh defending a a different kind of
anti-racism
um to go against the tide of the one
that's currently
sweeping at least elite circles
um in academia journalism you know
hollywood uh corporate america and so
forth
um uh but it's it's not
it's it's it's not a you know if you
wanna if you want a simple solution this
is not gonna be the book for you
so you don't think anti-bias training
based on critical race theory is the
answer
so far the evidence has not shown that
uh
implicit bias trainings reduce any kind
of racism that that we could measure
and um
you know i think what it does do is it
it alienates a lot of people
um you know i'm not i'm not
saying that there should be no kind of
diversity training in the in the context
of a workplace
but if the if the the sum total of
the training is to tell people you are
subconsciously racist in ways that you
can't
possibly you know by definition
consciously grab onto and
the solution is a kind of robin d'angelo
esque
groveling um you know
there's there's nothing to suggest that
that's the path forward
for harmonious relations between people
of different races
i spoke with chloe valderrie and she had
worked
you know chloe valderri probably she'd
worked on a uh
kind of an anti-racist or diversity
i guess you'd call it course and i
looked through her course and it was
way more reasonable than the like part
of the problem with this
anti-bias training i've had friends who
go through it or if they're working at
starbucks or something and it makes
people angry
to be to sit there and be talked at
about how they're
inherently racist like i i feel like
it's more likely to i don't know if
there's any there probably aren't any
studies on this but i feel like it's
more likely to
increase racism than decrease it if
you're just talking at people
about how they're evil like i'd be mad
about it
if i had to sit through that for a
couple of days especially if it was
based on robert d'angelo's stuff
i mean you know i've been in a classroom
at columbia where um
the a professor who who happened to be
white
though i think i would have been angry
either way said that all people
of color are victims of oppression
and you know i i wasn't i was furious i
was furious that um
she would characterize it that that
bluntly and that
broadly um i have to imagine the
experience of being told that you are by
definition of racist
which is uh what what robin d'angelo
proposes in her
in her massively successful best-selling
book white fragility
i have to imagine that that's also um
it's a non-starter for many people uh
it's it's
uh yeah i don't think that you know
many of these um social justice
inflected
bias trainings are inflected with a kind
of
kind of uh dominance and
and uh you know it's a kind of so so
for instance in d'angelo's book um
you know the thrust of the book is that
if you're talking to a black person
about race and you're white
uh you cannot disagree with them you
you can't do it it's immoral it's
unethical to to disagree with them
about anything related to race
right so what what that
essentially sets up is a completely
unequal relationship and i know what
people will say well they say let's say
in the broader context of
um you know a white supremacist culture
how can you possibly say that
um you know how can you possibly
complain
about you know white people being
mistreated
in any context since you know
whatever abstract ideas about uh you
know
uh white supremacist culture you have
can't possibly justify
a local explicit dominance of one race
by another
um how does that help counter the
alleged
white supremacist culture outside
there's never any proposed
link even between the two well and there
is no indication that those implicit
bias training programs have their
desired effect
i mean it's not it's very difficult to
design
psychological interventions that produce
positive effects
and it's very difficult to do the
studies necessary to
demonstrate that those effects exist and
when you're dealing with a phenomena
that's only weakly linked
to racial attitudes which would be say
implicit bias as measured by the
implicit
association test that's only weakly
linked to actual behavior
and then the training programs at best
have a
weak effect if it's not entirely
negative
it's not a solution to the problem that
we're discussing although
it has the advantage of looking like
it's a solution which
well which is often something that's
saleable right
something that looks like a solution
that's actually implementable
is saleable even if it doesn't have an
out the outcome that's desired because
what is being purchased isn't the
outcome
people purchasing it like who knows if
they even care
they they might just want to look good
right it's a lot easier just to look
virtuous than to actually be
well you could give them the benefit of
the doubt and say that they're likely to
be as virtuous
they're as likely to be virtuous as the
next person you know but these are very
difficult problems as
as coleman already pointed out they're
not going to be solved simply and if
you're a corporation that's
pushed to take noticeable action on
problems of
race the implicit bias training programs
at least
offer you the possibility of appearing
state of the art
and you might say well you have a
responsibility to assure that what
you're doing works
yeah you do yeah
and i i think corporations can't afford
to
adopt a tragic vision of human nature
like a like a writer can corporations
can't throw their hands up and say well
listen
we actually don't know the honest truth
is we do not know how to take someone
who
is biased racially or otherwise
and and change their fundamental
you know neural chemistry or personality
or whatever you want to call it
so as to make them less biased that is
something our species has not yet
figured out and frankly may never figure
out
because we we it's it's not just
inevitable that we will be able to fix
you know any any problem of course
corporations can't be seen
people mistake that for uh callousness
they mistake
a perhaps like a sober assessment of
what is possible and what's not
for not caring about the underlying
issue
and you know people in in whether
they're at corporations or in academia
or otherwise
um they lose face if they can ever be
construed as not caring about an issue
yeah yeah well that's partly why the
implicit bias training programs
have proved so popular you know in the
absence of an alternative solution
that's easily implementable and
and in keeping with the spirit of the
times
they dominate the marketplace and
it's probably not useful to be too
cynical about that
even though i think the tests the
programs are reprehensible
i understand why they're being employed
yeah the question i wanted to ask just
so i can sneak it in here
if you are i guess mandated to
take one of these uh diversity trainer
training or anti-bias programs say
as an employee of somebody and you're
not comfortable doing that or it's based
on
robin deangelo's work are there
suggestions you have for
for those people i threw up a couple of
questions on my instagram just
asking people if they had questions for
you and one of the main ones was
as a student or as a worker
how do you they use the term fight
back but what do you do if you're like
stuck in one of those anti-bias things
is there anything you can do
i really i really feel for people um
this is another area where i'm afraid i
have to say i don't
have a solution to that problem all i
have
is sympathy with the problem itself to
be stuck
in a scenario where you are asked to
hold your tongue
when you have eminently reasonable
things to say about the underlying issue
but you know that the moment you open
your mouth
there is nothing you can say clear
enough or profound enough to prevent
you from being labeled um
you know a bigot or
an uncle tom or what have you
and the reputational cost you pay
is likely to outweigh you know the
benefits
of having you know of having diversity
of opinion in the room and it's so much
easier to just stay
silent that's one way in
in which the faulty information
is so harmful right is is once
a false theory gets instantiated and a
false treatment program
if you question it your reputation is at
stake
but if you don't question it it can
never be replaced by something that
might actually work
so a bad theory in in that sense
at least of this type is worse than no
theory at all
because standing up against the bad
theory
appears to make you a bad person
yeah and ultimately it's a coordination
problem if there were enough people to
stand up to it at the same time
it wouldn't be a problem but there is a
this what what self-censorship
self-censorship
does is it makes every person in that
implicit bias
training who is having skeptical
thoughts in their mind
feel like they're the only person in the
room having such thoughts
yeah and they're not they're not right
right
that's why these kind of conversations
are important that's why what coleman's
doing is important too
is that if if you talk about some con
talk about
topics even you remember that black box
thing that happened on instagram where
everybody put a black box up which i
thought was
ridiculous but i woke up that morning
and i looked at my phone and everyone
had this black box up and i thought oh
my god
now i have to put a black box up on
instagram and then i thought
that is a ridiculous thought to have now
because you have to know that everyone
is noticing who doesn't put up the black
square
that's the most crucial part about the
black square yeah
so i didn't end up putting up a black
box because it i had that thought about
no now i have to and thought like no i
don't it's black box on instagram it's
not gonna make a difference to anybody
um but it is hard when you get this
like anyway i didn't put up the black
box and then i had a whole bunch of
people message me who had
this black box saying oh i really didn't
want to but i did anyway
i know at some point i mean it's
different i guess if you're going to
lose your job but
if you don't talk if you don't speak out
about some things that you think
are wrong you corrupt your soul well
that and isn't that how
entire societies get totally screwed up
like doesn't that can that potentially
screw up entire societies
yes it certainly certainly has that
propensity across time well coleman
you're
standing up to this like how is it that
you're able to manage that
practically and philosophically because
there's a practical side to
it um
there's an uncanny valley of
that i have successfully escaped
which means uh when you come out as a
heretic
on these issues
you you there's a price to pay an
immediate price to pay
that can last a long time in terms of
your
reputation your friendships your career
and so forth you're what yes
your mental health no doubt um
your family um and
but but on the other side of that valley
valley if you're
if you're if you're someone like me
which obviously
you know most people most people aren't
and can't
can't be because of circumstances
um and you have a podcast like i do
that's
grown a lot over the past six months and
you know i've put myself in a position
where i'm
successfully my own boss and i'm
i'm known as a heretic right so
i have i have nothing to lose from
further heresy
at this point um because i've lost
everything that i'm that i'm going to
lose
which makes it paradoxically easier
right you have to put yourself in a
position where you can sustain yourself
during that initial period of loss or
you have to be fortunate enough to be in
that position
and that that's not a situation that
characterizes many people
correct so what do you hope your book
will do
um that's a good question i mean i i
hope the book will be persuasive to
people who
are on the fence um
i hope it will give people who have a
gut level
doubt about race conscious
anti-racism the language to express
where their doubt might be coming from
i hope it i hope it
uh enlightens and i hope i hope people
get joy out of reading it i hope people
learn something it helps me writing it
helps me clarify my own thoughts
and i hope i i really hope for it to be
a book that people can read
20 and 30 years from now and
it will it would you know hopefully some
of the issues in question will have
gotten better by then
but i hope the book will still make
sense and resonate
um because you know this issue isn't
going away and i hope to write about it
in a way that isn't
merely responding to you know events of
the past six months but is actually
getting to
philosophical bedrock on the issues in
question
do you think things are going to improve
in the next couple of years
um in terms of uh the the the
prevalence of colorblindness versus race
consciousness
yeah just the tensions that we're having
now i mean it's definitely
gotten worse in the last six months so
do you see that
yeah do you continuing or i think that
if biden becomes president which seems
to be
a virtual certainty that the racial
tensions that characterize the united
states are actually going to decline
um so that's there are i think
two counter-veiling trends one is uh
you know the the the problem of
of woke anti-racism uh precedes
trump um and it is an is a
is a by and large a trend that
occurs independent of who is or isn't in
in the white house
so that will keep uh that the engine of
wokeness is going to keep running
um and he seems to have only been
getting more powerful in the past six
years
especially on the other hand i do think
that there were
there are lots of liberals
and centrists who uh
especially among elites that were so
alarmed
and uh appalled by trump's rhetoric
and his uh you know authoritarian
tendencies
um and you know his his
style um that they felt
um they felt that they couldn't
you know given the choice between
criticizing trump and criticizing the
far left
they felt more cautious criticizing the
far left
under a trump presidency than they might
now
under abide in presidency no that's an
interesting
that's an interesting idea so you think
a biden presidency might
give people the opportunity to liberal
people let's say this
opportunity to separate themselves from
their more radical
compatriots say within the democratic
party
it certainly offers that opportunity
whether or not people take it
is is anyone's guess frankly and i
wouldn't i don't want to signal too much
optimism on this score
but it's certainly an opportunity given
that biden has been fairly good
in rejecting most of the
policy prescriptions and sensibilities
of the far left
i think it would make sense for
um people of influence to rally around
him as
as um you know a
a a a president that hopefully will
embody actual liberal values
rather than um illiberal social justice
values
i was i was hopeful about that and then
harris put her pronouns in her bio
on twitter seriously i was like this you
know this actually maybe this isn't so
bad
i think biden might be more center than
he's putting on
um you know given his past but then
harris put her
her pronouns in her twitter i didn't
know that
yeah yeah so that that's not good
yeah he's phony no she doesn't mean it
yeah not that that makes it uh no that
might even
that might even be worse yeah i mean
isn't it i what i find to be strange is
the word
i have an obsession with this word
latinx
that's a bad one um i have an obsession
with this word i think it's it's partly
because
as a kid i grew up around my
spanish-speaking family members on my
mother's side often
and um you know by the time i was
adolescent i i wasn't fluent but i had a
you know
enough of a familiar familiarity with
the language to communicate
and when i got to colombia i heard this
word that i had never heard before in
all my days speaking to my puerto rican
family members
and it was sold as a word you know the
new polite term
for hispanic americans that
you know hispanic americans are
demanding much like the succession of
african american and black from the
earlier negro and colored which used to
be
the polite terms of course it's
it couldn't be further from the truth
right when pew polls hispanic americans
about what they prefer to be called they
find
95 96 say please don't call
call us latinx either i haven't heard of
that or i've heard of it and i don't
like it
um and so the you know so
it's one thing for there to be an elite
bubble how could there not be there's
nothing inherently wrong with that
everyone lives in a bubble
but what what strikes me with particular
force
is when the the elite
are completely unaware of how their
peculiar i should say our peculiar
moral sensibilities are not shared by
the general public
and therefore force their sensibilities
on the general public
you know there's nothing there's almost
nothing more philosophically repugnant
it's almost spiritually repugnant than
the attempt to force a particular
language usage
you know there's something about that
that's a deep violation of of
of individual freedom it's not obvious
how language evolves and how we all
accept new words but to have them coined
by ideologues and then forced
into usage by moral threats let's say
there there's there's something about
that that
that's it irks you
yeah it irks me too it it i i yeah i
mean
that yes um it it irks me very deeply
um it's an act of domination but but
it's an act of domination that that
is all the more pernicious for the fact
that the people doing the dominating
often don't even know it like like
you know elizabeth warren in her
presidential campaign
use the word latinx if you think about
it from her perspective
she should be desperate to win over the
95 percent of hispanics
she should be desperate not to alienate
them right she has every incentive to
and she still uses the word latinx the
question is why
and you know i can only think it's
because the hispanics in her immediate
circle
are all themselves elites within the
bubble who like this word
right so so the the
the the bubble that is not aware of
itself ends up
imposing things on on on
everyone else and um
just alienating the poppy i mean so
kamala
using putting her pronouns in her her
bio is is the example that that made me
think of this i mean
who who are what are you who are you
signaling to when you do that i think
you're signaling to
my peers that colombia are going to like
that
um but is the democratic base going to
like that
hell no you know the the democratic base
and the wider country of course not what
you're signaling to
what you're saying is i'm perfect
perfectly fine
alienating you know 70
of the country say um
if it means ingratia ingratiating myself
to this particular minority that has a
lot of cultural power and sway right now
and that sends that sends a very bad
signal if democrats keep doing that
they should be very worried about just
too i think you know that it would seem
to me to be more
logical in this early stage of the new
regime
to signal the ability to resist that
sort of temptation rather than
the willingness to be preemptively
intimidated
do you think she's maybe she's not even
intimidated
i mean maybe she is but maybe she's just
surrounded by
so many people telling her that that's
the right thing to do that she believes
it
is that possible i mean her circle might
be
a whole bunch of people who all have
their pronouns in their bio
no i think that that that is likely true
um and and who knows maybe they're
trying to play a split strategy where
biden plays to the middle and
kamala appeases the woke
true but we'll see
yeah well i i hope i hope that things go
well i mean obviously this transition is
a mess
um yeah i hope that the vast majority of
people up here in canada wish everybody
in the us well
while they while you go through this
convulsive process of
of changing your government and that
it's a change for the better that would
be something
it should not be convulsive i'm i'm
personally
embarrassed as an american that a
sitting president
is declaring victory um like
as if we're a third world nation that
struggles with
you know authoritarian dictators coming
to power it's embarrassing to me
well it is striking though how close
your elections have been
what for the last four elections
uh your country is so evenly split down
the middle that it's kind of miracle
or you could say the the parties just do
a very good job of
competing with one another is another
way of
thinking about it yes yes fair enough an
equally valid way of thinking about it
any idea when your book
is going to be finished and and then
also published
a depressingly long time from now so
much so that it's not worth dwelling
upon
oh well that's good it gives you
something important to do
continually and the opportunity as you
said to
to clarify your thoughts there's nothing
like protracted writing
to help you manage that
absolutely well
that that's usually when i call time
that's
about an hour if you want to continue
we can continue but uh i think we should
probably call it a night
especially with first podcast in two
years
well i think yeah i think um let me say
on behalf of
you know of everyone that you know the
world is very glad to have you back
yes well i'm very glad to be back
if i am in fact back so but it was
certainly a pleasure to be able to do
this tonight and and as i said to see
you again and to hear about what you're
up to i hope that
your endeavors continue to breed success
and that you have the best
of luck with your podcast thank you very
much
that podcast is conversations with
coleman by the way
you can subscribe to that on all the
normal
channels and routes where else can
people find
you you can find me on twitter at cold
x-man
you can find me at colemanhughes.org and
um
yep those are my main avenues
well thank you very much for coming on
my pleasure yeah thanks a lot
[Music]
absolutely
you